Although
generally in Australia, Canada, England and
Wales, Scotland, the U.S. and New Zealand
you cannot be subjected to a second trial
after a first has been completed, there are
exceptions.
What is Double Jeopardy?
Generally speaking, double jeopardy prohibits
a second trial where a criminal defendant
has been acquitted (autrefois acquit), convicted
(autrefois convict) or pardoned in a first.
This would not apply to such cases as depicted
in the 1999 film Double Jeopardy.
Without giving away too much of the plot,
in the film, they claimed she would get off
scot-free if she killed her husband again
after being convicted of killing him before.
This is not correct as these would be two
separate crimes, not to mention in separate
states.
It just so happened she was wrongly convicted
of the first.
In other words, if a person robs a store and
is convicted of it, then later robs the same
store, even with every detail of the crime
identical down to the clerk working and what
was stolen, the person can be tried again.
It’s very obviously still a separate crime.
(So in this case one of the core plot points
of the film turns out to be based on a false-premise,
not unlike the 2014 film Lucy where the protagonist
ultimately accesses the “other 90%” of
her brain and develops superpowers from it…
in truth, you actually use 100% of your brain
already.)
In any event, the idea of double jeopardy
arose naturally in the English common law
as early jurists realized the “anxiety and
insecurity” that ensued when people were
tried multiple times for a single crime.
Although this still remains a concern, and
the continued justification for the rule,
in many jurisdictions, there are ways in which
a person can be tried twice for the same offense.
The United States
The United States retains very strong prohibitions
against double jeopardy, although given its
system of federalism (where the federal and
state government may have overlapping criminal
laws), criminal defendants may be tried in
both state and federal courts for the exact
same criminal act.
This idea, first expounded in U.S. v. Lanza
(1922), is now known as the dual sovereignty
doctrine.
In addition, if a trial is begun, but it does
not end in judgment (guilty, innocent or acquitted),
the criminal defendant can often be retried.
This often arises in cases where a jury cannot
reach a decision (a hung jury), and a mistrial
is declared.
Canada
Unlike the U.S., in Canada, the provinces
have no authority to make criminal laws, so
as a result, only one jurisdiction, its federal
government, prosecutes crimes.
Not recognizing the concept of dual sovereignty,
at least according to some experts, Canada
applies double jeopardy even to prosecutions
that have occurred in other countries.
Canada’s double jeopardy rule also prohibits
the prosecution’s appeal of an acquittal,
except when it appeals “a point of law”
(as opposed to an appeal on the merits or
of a factual issue).
In this limited circumstance, if a procedural
deficiency is found, the matter can be retried.
England and Wales
Under English law, the prohibition against
double jeopardy may now be suspended in a
limited number of cases.
Born from the realization that modern scientific
forensic methods can reveal evidence that
was unavailable in years past, beginning in
2005, criminal defendants who had been previously
acquitted of a serious charge may be retried
if “new and compelling evidence” is brought
to light.
Crimes that reach the seriousness threshold
include murder, war crimes, rape and certain
drug offenses.
The compelling evidence that justifies a retrial
cannot have been available at the time of
the first trial.
Notably, this undermining of double jeopardy
protection applies retroactively – meaning
that people who were previously tried when
double jeopardy had its full effect, can now
be retried.
As a result, some criminal defendants who
confessed (or bragged) after their first acquittal
may now be tried again, based on that confession,
such as Billy Dunlop, who was convicted of
the 1991 murder of Julie Hogg in a 2006 retrial.
Note that, unlike in America, in the United
Kingdom, ex post facto criminal laws are merely
frowned upon, but not prohibited.
Australia
Also hoping to hold more people accountable
for serious crimes, in 2006, the Council of
Australian Governments (COAG) created a model
for double jeopardy reform to be instituted
by its member states.
By 2012, each state had some form of limited
exception to double jeopardy available to
retry a defendant in the face of a false acquittal
for charges of murder and other serious crimes
including gang rape and some drug offenses.
On May 1, 2014, multiple outlets reported
that Queensland authorities were proposing
to make its exception to double jeopardy completely
retroactive, although its earlier exception
applied only to trials after 2007.
If this proposed change is passed, retroactive
double jeopardy for certain serious crimes
will be the law across Australia.
Like the U.K., Australia does not prohibit
ex post facto criminal laws.
New Zealand
New Zealand generally prohibits retroactive
criminal laws, although its exceptions to
double jeopardy, passed in 2011, apply to
acquittals entered after June 2008.
These two exceptions are: where the criminal
defendant was acquitted through some criminal
action, and where “new and compelling evidence,”
is found in a serious case (defined as those
with a maximum penalty of at least 14 years
of prison).
As with other jurisdictions, this new evidence
could not have been available for the first
trial.
Scotland
Passed in 2011, the Double Jeopardy Act also
provides limited exceptions to the prohibition
against a second trial, and applies in cases
of a tainted acquittal or in light of “new
and compelling” evidence.
However, according to commentators, unlike
other jurisdictions the Scots law was broadly
written, such that it could apply to any offense
and leaves the decision to allow a retrial
largely to judicial discretion.
As a result, some commentators have opined
that the Scottish exception essentially eliminates
the entire protection, or as lawyers like
to say, created the “exception that swallowed
the rule.”